oh now tonight marks The Unofficial
start of the holiday season in southern
Nevada of course as the lights begin to
shine in Henderson Mercedes is at the
Ethel M cactus garden as we get set for
the official holiday cactus garden
lighting tonight there she is hey
Mercedes hey cute coat I love that hey
you two oh thank you we are so excited
one million twinkling lights are going
to be turned on tonight The Unofficial
start of the holidays we are at the
ethelm holiday cactus garden I'm here
with Lisa vanderson from ethelm Lisa
what can we expect tonight oh my gosh
it's gonna be beautiful it's such a nice
night to have like a hot cup or hot
chocolate with you yeah and wrap up in a
blanket and watch the lights turn on a
million lights are going to go on
Santa's here we're going to have a mini
tasting out here in the in the garden
for the teachers that we're honoring
this year and then at seven o'clock the
garden will open to the public now if
you want to come down here in the year a
couple years past since covid you have
to make a reservation what's the
situation this year you did so we've
gotten away from that we're not going
have reservations there is a one dollar
per person entry fee but all of that
will go to three square and food excuse
me Three Square Food Bank and help of
Southern Nevada that's great you guys
are helping out local charities and we
are so excited because I understand you
have a very special guest making his
official arrival tonight he's here he
said he left all the elves up at the
North Pole he's here you're gonna get to
see him in a bit uh and he's going to be
back taking pictures with the kids all
night Santa's here they're going to have
food trucks they're going to have sweet
and savory food for people to eat right
yes so if you have little kids that
maybe you just didn't have a chance to
make dinner before you come out we're
gonna have peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches a little personal style
pizzas so just a little bit of
everything for everyone this year and
also that if you want to you can sign up
for one of the wonderful chocolate
tastings that they have here at ethelm
that is so true and I'm not sure if a
lot of people know about that but our
tasting room is open again and you can
do a daytime tasting or in the evening
we're doing our holiday peace tasting
it's gonna be a great time I am
officially turning the lights on we are
high tech here I've got an app that I'm
using and you will see this glowing
we're going to check in a little bit
later Ted florendo's going to be here
and yeah it's going to be a great time
I'm going to send it back to you